Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get to a some notable discussions from
The David Pakman Show sub Reddit.
You can find the sub Reddit at David Pakman
dot com slash Reddit.
And now 31000 of you are subscribed for free
to the sub Reddit.
A user named Plentitude Opulence posted a
video of radical Republican Congressman Matt
Gates having a beverage thrown at him in Pensacola,
Florida.
Now, my position on this stuff has always
been the same.
I am against it.
I'm against it.
It is I know that this guy is disgusting.
I know that this guy is depraved.
I know that this guy represents so much of
what is wrong with the United States at this
point of time.
This time, I'm not denying that he's horrible.
If he has committed crimes, he should be charged
and he's currently under investigation.
He should be voted out, et cetera, et cetera.
But throwing drinks at people, you know, it's
just it's beneath us and I am against it.
So I know that the video went viral and people
are laughing and it's all a big party.
I think that this is you know, I'm not against
using incendiary language when it's appropriate
or engaging in hyperbole for a fact or whatever,
but throwing drinks at people.
I am against it.
I am very much against that and very much
the same user, William McAdoo or McDo, posted
to the sub Reddit.
This story of this anti mask, anti vaccine
police officer, 33 year old police officer
who has died of covid-19.
You know, when I see this, there are some
people who see this stuff and they gloat and
they say this guy deserved it and ha ha ha,
he denied that you need vaccines.
He was a Kova.
Denyer was against masks and now he's dead.
I take no pleasure in that.
I really don't.
And as I've said before, it's something about
me constitutionally, even when Rush Limbaugh
someone is disgusting, as Rush Limbaugh, who
made so many people's lives a living hell
by furthering homophobia and xenophobia and
all of the stuff, I take no pleasure in seeing
that Rush Limbaugh got lung cancer.
I take no pleasure in the fact that people
who loved him and there were people, I guess,
who did were are now or did suffer.
I take no pleasure in that.
And I take no pleasure in the fact that this
33 year old police officer, despite being
a covid Denyer, died.
I don't know.
I just I just can't do it.
And I know some people are taking pleasure
in it, but that is not for me.
For me, it's more about everybody could be
at risk and we should get vaccinated because
you might be one of those young people that
gets it and dies.
Why take the chance and the the covid-19 vaccine
is so effective that it makes the chance of
you dying from covid at any age group dramatically
lower and so go and get vaccinated.
That's the lesson.
The lesson is not, ha ha, somebody died.
It's go and get yourself vaccinated.
Lastly, on the sub Reddit user, be Ciccolo
posted if and it's a big if, it's proven that
the coronavirus did leak from the Wuhan Institute
of Virology, for which there is no public
evidence at this time.
Hypothetically, what would the international
reaction and response be?
China is arguably a superpower on the same
footing with the USA, EU, etc..
What consequences would they actually face?
Also in this hypothetical scenario, does war
with China become a serious platform idea
for the twenty twenty four Republican presidential
nomination?
Edit because I say I guess I should say it.
I do not believe the virus leak from the lab.
I suspect the overwhelmingly likely scenario
is it jumped from an animal in the wild.
Yeah.
So you know what's really funny about this?
Republicans love to say Joe Biden is going
to get us into all these different wars and
they like to say Joe Biden is soft on China.
And the reality is I don't think Joe Biden
is going to get us into any wars.
And Joe Biden has been reasonable on China,
in my estimation, if indeed there was the
discovery.
And I mean, listen, when we say if.
China obviously lied about cases early, they
seem to be lying about deaths.
There's no question in my mind China did tell
lies about what was going on with the pandemic
that's separate from the lab leak hypothesis.
OK, I do think that if the word war isn't
used, it's going to be probably something
else.
But if the lab leak hypothesis were to even
be proven partially and I'm not talking about
a bioengineered virus, but just it was being
studied and there was an accident.
Right.
For which there is no evidence at this time.
Very important to say.
I think you are going to see the closest to
just straight up the beating of war drums
from Republicans heading into